how's that that that's about two and a
half weeks old they're friendly very
very friendly call it Sir Richard
Branson's Jurassic Park okay I'm really
excited we're gonna get to go see some
lemurs 300 species live here many of
them have been hunted to near-extinction
or pushed out of their natural habitats
by developers on Necker Branson's
private island in the British Virgin
Islands
the billionaire collects them and makes
sure they thrive all right so you go
first thank you
these are red ruffed lemurs they're one
of the most imperil there's only about
three or four hundred has left in the
world for Branson saving animals is both
a passion and a crusade he's carved out
six acres for their playground and he
employs a team of three wildlife experts
to care for them full-time we've taken
them from zoos where they weren't
breathing because this space was so
small giving them a lots more space yet
and they're not really well Necker is
home to six nearly extinct species of
lemurs native to Madagascar would you
say they're thriving in this kind of man
driving in this environment yes these
black and white lemurs like your food so
much so that okay I'll admit it made me
a bit so I don't have any uncomfortable
to say the least
thankfully the giant galapagos tortoises
don't get as excited about mealtime in
fact they can live months without food
this one is 30 years old but 30 may be
the new 18 because she's gonna live till
200
Branson has spent hundreds of thousands
of dollars on animal conservation in
addition to tortoises and lemurs Necker
shelters some rare birds McGurn here was
actually born blind and they've hand
feeding him and it's doing very well
the scarlet ibis up yeah oh I see one
right there the scarlet ibis was once
native to this area of the Caribbean by
the time Richard moved here there wasn't
a single one left I think that because
they're so beautiful they maybe were
killed for their feathers they
disappeared but Richard Branson has big
plans for them once we have enough here
they'll start moving out on to other
islands and hopefully one day the
British Virgin Islands will have scarlet
ibis white ibis flamingos and all the
poems but if I were an animal on Necker
I'd never leave I know breakfast is here